wait who is mr falcon no one then why did
he say it well in the real version he said
a bad word but they had to change it for
tv tv is so lame what did he really say
that's so much better this
movie works on a lot of levels
son of a mitch melissa cooper what i said
mitch there's nothing wrong with that
but you meant another word i'm sorry what other
word just watch it hold on so you're saying if
i have a friend whose dad's name is mitch i'm not
allowed to talk about him i know what you're doing
okay i just feel bad for my friend that poor
son of a mitch melissa cooper why didn't you
eat with us i'm not hungry dad's mad at me mom's
not thrilled with me either why mom made chicken
and i said chickens cluck a lot so they should
be called cluckers and some chickens are moms
so you could call them mug care mom sure did what
did you do wrong i got dad in trouble with the irs
he has to hire an accountant which could cost us
a lot of money dang makes me not want to have kids
hey hello playing with your train
i'm punishing myself by looking at them
but not allowing myself to run them
you don't have to punish yourself because you'd
rather do it that's fair no it's okay i deserve it
actually i want you to represent us at the
altar but i messed everything up you did
i also know if anyone's smart
enough to get us out yes you are
why'd you change your mind no reason
what did the accountant say nothing they
said my returns were perfect didn't they
play with your trains
why are you reading the bible i felt bad about
last night so i thought it might be good for me
where are you going with this
nowhere i just want to make you happy
and the man increased exceedingly and had much
cattle and maidservants and men servants in camels
and asses okay stop what i'm just reading
from genesis well cut it out fine let's try
exodus and on the seventh day thou shalt
rest that thine ox and my ass may rest
that is it you are grounded for reading the bible
the way you are doing it yes go to your room okay
i don't have a donkey but if i
did i take my ass out of here
do
so
you